subway wait I should not be on the phone
okay why why did you jump scare me with
fruit with your leg what are you talking
about word for flying little dope okay
just need to wind up quick like sanic a
my legs are broken
City Park or how wrong can this
oh my goodness harpoon Dodd's really
whoa Oh slam dunk okay old man why okay
that was interesting
now I'm writhing in a pile of old men
again yes I'm here to save you prize
I'll burn a word son brother there's a
lot worse in this world the dying to be
or tidy in these other traps that we
have it here okay different but somehow
the pain is still familiar in my
testicles it's awesome I don't even care
of my arm broke I oh okay that might be
okay girl soon to freak it out oh this
is too much power and I've lost
everything I just pooped out my own leg
with I so I didn't need that oh sorry
about that I'm just trying to make do
okay that's bad I apologize for that
I gotta admit this is really cool but a
little bit Oh frustrating come on yes
yes
don't die no no oh god what have you
done to me Oh
Green sword throw with the swords on our
green how do you present this shareable
keys George knows best in every possible
way it's actually great that there are
no hydraulic one for size Oh Oh got me
Oh
ha you thought you could beat me yeah
get out of my way wait outside seemed
like it hurt more for you than me ok
lady I know this is precariously setup
to let you live but just silly warning
what warning twenty mother
Oh
markiplier test oh I just did one of
these before it was a quiz of epic
goodness see I got it okay well at least
we're together kid okay didn't know I
was so flexible okay could you stop that
well I failed the markiplier test but
that's alright there goes my balls oh
just got a prospect me my kid
nice head roll kid how you doing Santa
alright Oh Phil seems to be just fine
Santa's gonna just mosey on here with
his bastard titties oh I couldn't read
that thank you
markiplier jump I wonder how far we're
gonna go on this one it's probably
cheating that I'm trying to fly where am
I going
whoa what was that
Margalo puck swag okay okay all right
this is normal well maybe this is just
the best for me
hello markiplier come here oh my god hi
how can i how do i oh there I go my
pelvis really this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
want to see more happy wheels right now
check the description or click the
annotation for the full happy wheels
playlist and if you want to see more
happy wheels in the future please click
the like button to let me know thanks
again everyone and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
you